all right pulling up to Khloe's birthday
et is taking you inside Khloe
Kardashian's lavish and oh so pink 35th
birthday bash happy birthday thank you
special for the birthday just family
gathering gathering was putting it
lightly the car Jenner's went full out
for Khloe hiring Jeff Latham and Mindy
Weiss who decorated in all pink
everything I'm talking pink food
including pink grilled cheese for chef K
only offers food with pink cheese and a
pink cake
yeah even the straws were pink striped
with Chloe's face on them the happy
birthday Coco napkins in pink writing
pink florals pink flower petals in this
fountain Khloe and true in different
shades of pink
are you wearing my oh my goodness you
look beautiful truthful there was even a
pink photo booth auntie Kylie's setup
the coolest photoshoot opportunity it's
a luck we have to wait for the Sun to go
down these BOTS cloak em and no party is
complete without a bull to ride on
because it happens things seemingly did
get a bit wild Kendal passing out shots
two party guests other fun treats
include birthday shirts for people to
wear or take home the custom drink menu
and her infamous quotes plastered all
over the place damn damn too close and
how precious is little dream came showed
off her gift for Chloe I got her this
Judith Leiber bag have an eggplant and I
just thought it was really fitting for
her and she loves it guys the family
also taped messages for Chloe happy
birthday to my favorite sister Chloe I
just want to tell you I love you happy
birthday Chloe I'm so thankful
[Music]
happy birthday
best birthday ever let me know what you
guys thought of the bash though and for
all the latest on the Kardashians keep
it locked to all things ET I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now